- What's up with you guys?
Thanks for coming through.
- [Murs] Thanks, man.
- [Gary] Yeah.
Where do you guys live?
- [Murs] I live in Sherman Oaks.
- [Jay] I live in Inglewood.
- [Gary] That's great.
Born and raised?
- [Murs] I'm born and
raised in mid-city LA.
Both born and raised in LA.
- [Gary] Awesome.
Glad you guys came through.
So what's been going on, anything good?
- Just dropped an album
and waiting on my wife to
drop a baby any day now.
- [Gary] So everyone's dropping projects.
- [Murs] Yeah, so I'm just
like looking at my phone like--
- Like every second, right?
I remember the first one too.
My phone buzzed and I was like,
it was the only time my phone ring was on
in the last 10 years.
- [Murs] Yeah, exactly.
- 'Cause I was so nervous.
- [Murs] I'm so nervous to turn mine off.
- I was so pumped.
It happened on a Saturday.
And how's the project doing?
- It's good, man.
Good for an old rapper.
I'm out there, you know,
I talk about a loss on the album,
so it's kinda like a depressing,
something that hasn't been done in rap.
So a lot of people come out saying,
"Thank you for talking about it."
But I think a lot of
people are kinda like,
"Ah, I don't wanna turn up to this."
- [Gary] Of course.
Every project's got a different,
you gotta speak your truth.
- Yeah, so I'm happy with it.
I'm happy with my label.
- [Gary] Supporting that.
- Yeah, they knew where I was,
and I was like if I come outta this hole,
there's a record for you guys,
this is what it's gonna be.
And they're like...
- [Gary] Go do your thing.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] How about for you?
- Me, I was just working with Nick.
Our relationship's weird 'cause
I work in advertising.
We just kinda came across each other
just working, what was it like, 2013,
we did a project together.
And then I brought him on to do like
three or four more projects.
And I've worked with a ton of artists.
But working with him,
he just kinda gets it.
You know, we just--
- [Gary] How do you define gets it?
Understands the end consumer?
- Yeah, he understands
the business side of it
as well as the art side.
Then just understands how
to work the clients as well,
and knows what they're looking for.
You know, outside of that,
I think we've been trying to work together
outside of advertising, trying
to create our own content.
He has a certain charisma about him
that goes beyond just rap.
- OG in the Twitch game.
- [Gary] I'm Aware.
I think he's got,
he could definitely be a host.
We did a Facebook live and
pop show for Boost Mobile
a couple years ago, on Where You At LA?
And he was essentially
the host of that show
and he brought in a bunch of artists.
He's respected by--
- [Gary] Culture.
- The most hip hop guys.
- [Gary] Yep, I'm aware.
- And like the most sensitive
females like his music.
And so he appeals to a mass audience.
He could stretch his
wings beyond just rap.
Even though he's a fantastic rapper.
- [Gary] And how are
you thinking about that?
Is that what you want or?
- That's just, that's what
I'm dealing with now, so.
- [Gary] Trying to figure out that--
- This was my last album
with the label so I'm free.
- [Gary] Yes, which must feel interesting.
- Yes.
- [Gary] Options.
- Yeah, exactly.
I got gigs, like the people
that want me for personality,
"You should do a podcast."
I'm hosting HipHopDX, the biggest show,
and I took them, to at one point
eight million views on one
video, took 'em 18 months.
I did it in three months for them.
Their subscribers have grown by 100,000,
so they want me to stay on,
they want me to be the
content creator of all videos.
And it's kinda like Joe Button.
When Joe Button went public,
he had to kill his rap career,
which I think made sense
because everybody tries
to straddle the fence
seems to get lost.
People on the hosting--
- Why do you think he did that?
You think he loved it or
he just thought it was
economically the right move for him?
- I think economically and I think
he's into being a dad now.
You wanna make money at rap
you gotta be everywhere,
you gotta go around, shake hands,
you gotta stand in VIP, you gotta,
and then you gotta deal
with a lot of flack.
I put out my album professing my life
and Pitchfork gave it a 6.8.
It's like, fuck, you know like, right.
But when I create these content
I'm talking about other rappers
and putting together these words
and the advertisers are
streaming video games,
I don't deal with as much,
you know, it's not my heart.
It's what I love doing it
'cause I love the culture,
but I'm not so invested in it,
and I don't have to be on the road
100 days, 200 days outta the year.
- [Gary] I totally understand.
- But it's still a good job.
Like if my rap album wasn't selling
and I wasn't getting offers
to do tours and gigs,
I would have dropped it
and stayed at HipHopDX
but it's still like,
You know, I don't know which way to go.
- [Gary] And what do
you do in advertising?
- I work at social.
- [Gary] Where?
- I work at MullenLowe now,
I was at 180 LA before that.
Where he's working.
- [Gary] You've been in the
agency world for a long time?
- Yeah, four almost five years now.
- [Gary] And before that?
- I was working in music.
I was a DJ, and I ran
a small record label.
Kinda doing stuff that
lead to advertising.
Just 'cause I already had
a, working on the internet.
- [Gary] I've heard.
- So when I got in, it was
just basically Twitter.
They hired me 'cause they needed someone
to run Boost Mobile social account.
They needed someone to do marketing,
the knew (mumbling).
So I just kinda fell into it.
And before I knew it it just
kinda, worked my way up.
- [Gary] I love it.
- This game's crazy.
Me going out, going to
meetings with him and then
this person gets poached by this agency,
next year they're working here,
then a year they're working
back at this agency.
I'm like, oh you mother fuckers are just,
ad game's wild.
- [Gary] I agree.
- Come to a meeting here,
we're having this party
Friday night, come to this.
I'm like didn't he used to work here,
and you used to work, and
everybody knows each other,
but they all...
- [Gary] I agree.
'Cause they don't have to sign
contracts that lock them in.
(laughing)
- [Murs] That's why it's so bizarre.
You were just on Def Jam yesterday.
- I upload, it was weird as
hell to me when I first started.
You're leaving already?
You've only been here like six months.
That's how, in this industry,
that's how you work your
way up is just like,
they're not really gonna promote
you internally that quick.
If you wanna just like take
that little tiny steps.
The agencies aren't advancing
people that quickly.
- I couldn't agree more.
It's the biggest thing I noticed
when I first started Vayner.
I didn't realize when
people would tell me,
I don't know--
- It's a margin game, right?
- Yeah, that's right.
All the agencies, the company
you work for right now
is a huge publicly traded company.
They don't give a fuck about you.
You're a line item.
I've said this before,
I don't know if you've ever
heard me say this, Judy,
and this is the truth.
If I actually understood the
advertising industry's dynamic
between employees and holding companies,
I would have never started VaynerMedia.
That's real life.
'Cause I hate when
people leave my company.
I hate it.
I love continuity.
You even know the way I talk when we,
like I'm really trying to figure out
how to make it forever,
or at least a long, long, long time
so that when it happens it feels like
cool and awesome and right,
not, "Oh I need to be
at a place for 18 months
"and then leverage."
And now because our brand is so strong,
a lot of the kids do think I know
that are coming in this
is a great launching pad
because this is a good brand right now.
And you know the more traditional shops
want kids that we're grooming.
People get caught up in short
term thinking, you know?
People just, people are
confused by abundance.
People think that they
need to take something
that somebody else is gonna get
without realizing there's so
much for everybody to eat.
Tonight America's gonna
throw out more food,
food that America throws out tonight,
could feed so many parts of the world,
we just don't think, we
think of things in silos.
There's so much more to go around.
And everybody's grabbing 'cause they think
that's the only, like it's all around us,
and I just watch it.
And I'm like, I never think
that somebody's victory
is at my expense.
If I was a rapper, like literally,
if whoever has the biggest
song in the world right now,
I would never think oh my God,
that dude or that woman is
getting all the listens.
(laughing)
Like, you know what I mean?
- [Murs] That's how people act.
- That's how people act.
Like, you know, just talking
about current hip hop.
I don't, I would hope that Nicki Minaj
or the people around her
don't sit there and say,
"Well, Cardi B's taking our listens."
I understand that's an
easy, lazy thing to say
if you're not thoughtful.
If Nicki Minaj puts out a
fucking fire track right now,
people are gonna listen.
- [Tyler] 'Cause yeah, it doesn't matter.
- There's abundance.
- [Tyler] Especially
now that music is free.
- There's abundance.
- [Murs] Yeah, I don't understand it.
- But that's the confusion
in the system, you know?
And so people need a
calibration of understanding
how much food there is to eat,
and I think everybody needs more empathy.
To me that's so stuck in
my right here right now.
You starting with a new label.
You're gonna be a different
version of yourself
than if it's the third label,
third album with a label,
because you may for your
own ambition and skillset
wanna prove something, or
start off the right way.
So there's so much context
in every interaction,
in every transaction.
That's what I spend all
my time on, empathy.
- [Murs] That's rare.
- I think so, but that's also why I think
I have rare results.
Basically it's a very
basic business thing,
if you can survive doing it
the way that nobody else is doing it,
if you have the ability,
and this is what I have,
to sell it to keep you
alive to give you leverage
to then be able to afford
the thing that everybody
else does, you win.
That's the story of Vayner.
We could stay alive in 2009,
10, 11, 12, doing social media
when nobody wanted to buy it.
Biggest companies in the world are like,
"I got $5,000 a month for you for
"fucking four full time staff
"to do social media full rack."
But I could stay alive and then
it became the market and,
it's how we're gonna build
the biggest media property.
We're gonna build the biggest media agency
on the back of doing all the stuff right.
And then we're gonna
buy a television shop.
Commodity, that's where
the dollars are now,
but as that goes like this,
that will all die, even
though it's even to the spend
on let's say Facebook and Google,
but I'll be able to buy it
'cause the infrastructure
costs are gonna collapse it.
Toys R Us does plenty of revenue.
It's outta business.
You know, plenty people make
a million dollars a year,
they just spend $1.1 million.
Antoine Walker made $100 million.
You know, it doesn't
matter how much you make.
Matters what you spend, you know?
So I spend a lot of
time thinking that way.
It's how I think about
attention, by the way.
making things successful.
You know, what are you gonna spend your,
this, this for me is a bad
use of my short term time,
what they're paying me
for this one pilot episode
over three days, is a bad use of my time
in the three day period, but if it pops,
it's gonna hit an audience,
you know, I'm gonna win the internet.
Over the last 15 months, you guys know.
And the next three
years will be even more,
I'm gonna win.
But there's still at least for now,
49 year old Karen, I'm
not gonna get to her
the way I'm gonna get as
being like a star of show.
So it's just trying to
figure out the right pieces.
Anything I can help you guys with?
You know obviously I'm aware about your--
- Yeah, I just wanted to ask
rapping or personality or trying
to Bo Jackson and do both?
- I think Bo Jackson.
I'll tell you why.
You can always do the other.
You can always default into
picking one or the other,
but if you can do Bo Jackson creatively
and filling your soul, like to me,
to make a binary decision that now
I'm gonna just play on my, you know,
you have these abilities,
you know, listen,
it's what I'm doing.
I'm doing all sorts of
shit because if I can,
you know the reason I
wouldn't do this show
is if I felt like last year proved to me
that I was incapable.
But that didn't happen.
I feel like I am capable.
I work a lot, which
allows me to kind of like
close the gaps on doing things.
I also know what this
means to our business.
So to me, you know, here's
how I think about music,
and I really wish I had that skillset
in today's environment of distribution.
The fact that I could get inspired,
go into the fucking
studio, break off a song,
and literally just drop it
on SoundCloud or Spotify
and use my own social to build awareness,
and if it's real, like if it's got,
literally somebody who builds awareness
and has some social and has
the ability to produce a song,
and nobody's in charge of your
distribution or your marketing,
and then you let the music
speak for itself is remarkable.
- [Murs] Yeah, it's a different time.
- I mean, I'm 42.
When I think about going and
getting signed by a label,
producing an album, the marketing,
the Virgin fucking mega
store selling your shit,
MTV or BET having to
give you love, or Z100.
Like all that's gone.
The middle's dead.
You, your audience, SoundCloud, Spotify.
Upload for fucking free, let's go.
Are you fucking kidding me?
So you could be
personality, you could be--
- [Murs] That's the thing,
I feel like sometimes
I'm pulling my fan base in
too many different directions.
- Disagree, nope.
- [Murs] Like when I go on Twitch
every day they say,
"Why aren't you rapping?
"Where's your album?"
- Yeah, where is your brand.
- Nope, nope, disagree.
I get it, 'cause you're
fucking music's fire
and they want more music.
But the fact that they even took the time
to go on Twitch and tell
you that is already,
never worry about people
that are talking to you.
Worry about the people
that stop talking to you.
My dad used to get super bent outta shape
when we got a complaint.
I'm like Dad, I love complaints.
You know what, perfect.
I wanna hear everything.
'Cause when I'm not hearing
it, I'm not in control.
When somebody came into
Wine Library back in the day
and didn't have a good experience,
like me, I'm dangerous as a customer.
I go to a restaurant,
if the waiter fucking
punches me in the face,
I won't say a word.
I don't know how to complain,
but I just will never go back.
Like the waiter punched me (laughing).
I would suck my bloody lip, eat my food,
leave, not talk to the
manager, not make a scene.
If you look at all, I don't
know how many tweets I have,
not one complaint.
You know how many times I've
had a shitty experience?
Not fuck you, Delta,
not fucking this, nothing.
I don't have it in me.
It's not how I was raised.
What I do is I chose not to go back.
- [Murs] That's worse.
- To me if somebody's
saying they're mad at me,
means they care.
Means they're still in the circle.
Means I can learn from it.
To me it's the people who just unfollow
and never said anything about it.
Got it?
So to me when you're getting that feedback
it's only showing love to a skill you have
and they just wanna be fed some more.
But I don't think that's the
reason to stop doing something.
I think that's the reason to do all of it.
- [Murs] You think the jack
of all trades, master of none
is the--
- Is a farce.
- [Murs] Wow.
- Yes I do.
I think a lot of these sayings
are from times that don't exist anymore.
For example, fake it til you make it.
Can't fake it til you make it anymore
'cause while you're faking
it, it's your public domain.
Like you can't, if you're
gonna come out and say
you're a 22 life coach, you
can't fake it like you used to.
Everything's being documented,
everything's being watched.
No I don't think so, man.
I think a lot of people
are multi-dimensional.
I also think you're in a funny business.
If you're in the music business,
you're one at bat away from everything,
you're one song away
every day of your life.
- [Murs] And that's why it's so hard
to walk away from it.
- You can't, brother.
Why do you think I'm talking to you?
(laughing)
You can't walk away from a game
that literally one fucking
song and you're back.
It's acting too.
John Travolta was dead for 16 years.
And then Pulp Fiction, my man.
So fuck that.
You can never give up on music.
You're one fucking song away.
(mumbling)
Very.
- [Murs] Music save my life.
- It's also your art and
your personal expression.
- [Murs] Yeah, and I love it.
- Yeah, yeah.
(mumbling)
- Now it also depends on
your artistic process.
Lotta stuff's easy for me
'cause I'm straight improv.
Like Judy and I can go pitch right now
our biggest piece of business
in the history of LA,
and I'm not gonna prep.
She'll be ready.
I'll be ready with what
I have to be ready for.
- Makes me nervous.
I'll be ready with what
I have to be ready for.
I'll be ready for, I'll be ready for what,
I mean I go out there,
I don't know anything about the business,
I pick up, I don't know any,
like I can pick shit in four,
I listen in three
seconds, I'm like got you.
That's what I'm good at.
So I would have been, like
I always wish I could rap
because I'd be like,
that'd be great for me,
I'll just go and fucking spit
it from the top of my dome
and be out, no writing, no nothing,
I'll just go do it.
It's why I want, like one of
the biggest reasons I want
this to pop is I just wanna...
- Really?
- Yeah, I'm like I think I would kill it.
- [Murs] I know you would kill it.
- Yeah, I would kill it, I feel.
I think my opening dialogue
would motivate a generation
and then I'd go and do some funny shit.
I think it'd be good.
- I really want you to do that.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- [Tyler] I do too.
- It'd be the second episode
I watched in my life.
- [Gary] I appreciate, what was the first?
- I believe it was,
probably the Dave Chapelle.
- Oh yeah.
Oh my God.
What is this?
- Aw.
- Pooch.
Super star on the scene.
What the hell's--
- She heard that I do.
She's like--
- I want a piece of the action.
- [Murs] Holy shit,
someone's just letting
this thing walk around.
- This thing.
(laughing)
I hope she's gonna pitch me.
I'll buy.
(laughing)
- [Murs] But yeah, that's it.
- That's it man, that's the answer.
- [Murs] The album, I do an album,
my best selling album I did in five days.
- I love it.
- [Murs] Album that
people call my best album,
it took me five days.
"What are you doing?"
- This was a podcast I heard you do
when you mentioned next big artist
that's gonna release a
track a day for like a year,
or something like that.
- [Gary] I believe in it.
I think it's at bats.
- I think this guy should do that.
- [Gary] I think it's at bats.
- I actually told you about this a while.
- Yeah, I know you told me.
I was like I can do it.
- Here's what I think about you.
I don't think you're capable
of putting out something
that is detrimental to you.
That's what I don't
think people understand.
I think you're too talented
from what I know about you
to put out anything that's detrimental.
And you know this.
I put out my heart and this
is the rating they gave me.
Things that you thought
were gonna be the song
that was gonna change
your career, nothing.
Songs that you didn't pay
attention to meant something.
I do it with content too.
Like I'm like this is gonna be the fire.
Huh?
And it's like, and then
like what up, you know,
that's so common, that's so
right, it's advertising too.
It's the way the world actually works.
It just means it's, to me
it just leaves so much,
to me creativity is,
like I'm fairly creative
in the scheme of things,
now that I've gotten to
know myself a little bit
as I've gotten older.
But like, I don't know,
you can't, like literally
this happened this morning,
we walked in here, he's like,
"Can you put on for the vlog?"
And like we can't film much here.
So I was like unmotivated
so I literally took it off,
which I never do.
- [DRock] I put my camera away.
- I was like I don't wanna do this.
Right, literally.
- [DRock] And then four minutes in.
- Four minutes later
off of reading something
in my Instagram, I'm like, DRock,
let's go make, and I, now
because we do the vlog,
I rarely do what I did three years ago
which is get inspired,
ask somebody for a camera
to come and see me and I would rant.
My content in 2012 to like
15, most of the YouTube thing,
would be I was inspired,
luckily somebody was around with a camera,
I'd rant about something like
Wall Street's wrong about this
or I believe Twitter's
gonna do this, right.
Now I never do it 'cause
we're filming everything
and I don't need to and
I don't think that way.
This was the first time
I've done it in six months.
- [DRock] The last time like (mumbling).
- Oh yeah, we did actually.
Anyway, nonetheless, four
minutes earlier I'm like
I don't even wanna be mic'd,
four minutes later I'm like I wanna make
an original piece of content
off the top of my head.
That's how I think about
music now which is like
how amazing is it if you can
just do it when you feel it
and not be confined to the
creative or the distribution,
I mean that's it, you got it.
- [Jay] Used to be like three months.
You gotta get it to the source and
wait for that three months to get--
- [Gary] Fuck that.
Fuck that.
And now, especially if you're
OG in the Twitch community,
you fucking, you make a crew,
if Ninja's listening to your shit
while he's playing Fortnite right now,
like that's more listens than
fucking iHeartRadio's gonna give you.
People are fucking confused, man.
People are fucking confused.
This is, MTV 1984.
People are confused.
The biggest bands in the world
didn't make music videos 'cause they
thought it was giving away free music.
They didn't get it.
They were thinking short term.
Styx didn't make music videos.
They were one of the
biggest bands in the world.
'Cause they thought it was free music.
"Fuck you, this new thing MTV.
"We're not gonna fucking make
music, you're gonna play it.
"Our people can go to the
record store and buy our shit."
Until nobody knew who the fuck they were
'cause Duran Duran and Van Halen and
fucking Twisted Sister
were playing on loop
and then they became the biggest bands.
Exposure.
Listens.
Some kid who's got fucking
two million people watching
them play Fortnite, playing
your track while they're playing
is a hell of a lot more
than Z one fucking hundred.
- [Murs] Going to all these conventions,
hanging out with the top twenty.
I've made PUBG, that's my homeboy.
I met him drinking.
Irish dude start drinking.
- That's the Fortnite equity, right?
(mumbling)
- [Murs] He was like, yo.
- You know how I do it.
China.
- [Murs] But my label, I'm like,
yo we need to get our
music in this guy's game
and my label was like, "We
don't give away music."
I'm like this guy's game is gonna be,
and no one believed me,
and I'm hanging out
with all these streamers
and I'm like yo, they wanna be able
to play our shit, you
just have to watch it.
- That's how I think
about media, you know.
It's all I think about with media.
Overpriced, under priced.
They think hoarding Pitchfork is like,
I don't give a fuck about anything.
Any established thing
doesn't mean anything,
it doesn't have the leverage,
its leverage is overrated,
its leverage is overrated.
Whatever the establishment is, overrated.
I don't know what else to say.
- [Murs] They don't want
it til it's too late.
But it's great now that
Twitch is the thing.
But for me I've been
doing it for two years.
People are like, "What
is this video game."
I won't say his name, but famous rapper
was managing a friend of
mine, he's a friend of mine,
flew me in like, "How
much do we charge Twitch?"
a year ago.
I'm like you don't charge Twitch.
They're like, "They want us
to stream on their thing."
I'm like you should do it because
Amazon just bought them for $980 million.
They're like, "What?"
I'm like how do you not know this.
They flew me in to
educate them about Twitch.
But they still didn't know.
But now Drake did it and it's like.
- [Gary] Of course.
- And I was like--
- It always is gonna be a moment.
Snapchat until Khalid did it.
Twitter before Ashton
Kutcher jumped on it.
It's all the same fucking game.
We know it's happening.
But the culture and the
mainstream need that moment.
And I just spend all my time
trying to be at that moment beforehand
so when the moment happens.
- Right.
I haven't streamed in a long
time because of the album.
- [Gary] I get it.
I mean I almost did Twitch
before I did YouTube
with Stunwin, before you
were even on my team.
Talking about three and a half years ago.
Like, you know.
(laughing)
- We streamed Murs' rap
25 hour stream on Twitch.
And we did it at the same
time Boost did it on YouTube.
And Twitch (mumbling).
- It's not even close.
Guys, Twitch's continuous
minutes trump everything.
- [Jay] Literally the same
guys were there for 25 hours
watching this crazy ass guy.
- I'm thinking about
just going Twitch 24/7.
I'm like fucking live stream live
for the rest of my life on Twitch.
Just go back to what it was.
Twitch was done by Justin.
- [Murs] Justin TV, yeah.
- iJustine, that's how she blew up.
- [Murs] Oh really?
- Yeah.
You know, Justin TV, iJustine TV.
She was, Justine, that's how
she blew up back in the day.
- [Murs] That's wild.
Incorporating music as
into everything else.
- To me it's just so much
under priced attention.
You go and DM 55 influencers on Instagram
with two million followers and ask them
to just put a minute of your music
in whatever video they're using.
It's just more exposure than Z100.
I don't know what else to tell you.
It's nothing personal.
You know, it's nothing, sorry.
Like I don't know,
would you rather be a
Netflix hit show now or,
you know a Bravo hit show.
Netflix.
Five years ago, Bravo.
10 years before that CBS.
50 years before that,
fucking radio channel XYZ,
before that drawn in a cave.
Shit changes.
Right?
I don't know, like that number one drawer.
Caveman John, his shit is fly.
(laughing)
Attention moves.
MTV's bunk.
Was 1986, nothing was more important.
Everybody in the music industry
just sat in a room be like,
"Alright, this music video's
gonna make us or not" right.
So, I mean I'd much rather,
I wish everybody would
Torrent my latest book.
I don't want the money,
I want the attention.
- [Murs] Yeah, that's what
I tell people all the time.
Just like steal my music, I don't.
- I do it all the time,
I go on all these shows,
like hip hop shows, like,
"You've got a new book out."
And you know the host
is trying to do right.
Charlamagne would be like,
"Yo everybody go out and buy it."
And I'll jump in and be
like no, no, don't buy it.
Go download that shit for free.
(laughing)
And then (mumbling) I'm like yes.
They love that.
(mellow music)